no
ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález omicron es la
más reciente variante del saco dos en
ser detectada es hasta ahora la variante
más mutada hasta la fecha y es el nuevo
foco de atención de las autoridades
mundiales de las autoridades sanitarias
de los gobiernos de los medios de
comunicación y de la población veamos
las variantes de kobe 19 que están
circulando hasta ahora en estos poco más
de dos años de la aparición de la
pandemia de kobe 19 pues vemos que las
variantes de preocupación de la ms han
sido alfabeta gama delta ahora se une
omicron y han sido descubiertas en el
reino unido en sudáfrica en brasil india
y esta última fue detectada en sudáfrica
pero su origen es todavía un misterio
puede haber tenido su desarrollo en otro
país en otra parte del planeta dentro de
las variantes de interés para la o&m es
esta lambda y moon ambas desarrolladas
en o descubiertas en sudamérica lambda
en perú y mu en colombia
como lo decíamos om y chrome es una
variante de preocupación según la oms
porque o micro es muy diferente a la
versión original del virus cuando fue
encontrado en la ciudad de wuhan en
china la comunidad científica investiga
si esta variante es más contagiosa si
produce síntomas más fuertes y es más
importante aún si es más resistente a
las vacunas o no y si existen alguna
forma de combatirla rápidamente veamos
los países que ya han comenzado a
reportar casos de esta variante vemos
que ya llegó a américa latina entró por
brasil un país que hace unas cuantas
horas después registró el primer caso
europa es el continente en donde más
países han reportado casos ya lo vemos a
austria españa bélgica al reino unido
alemania sólo por mencionar algunos los
países bajos la república checa portugal
que es el país que más casos tiene hasta
el momento y suiza- en la región de
asia-pacífico está israel la ciudad
autónoma de hong kong en china japón y
australia y en áfrica hay casos
reportados en botsuana en sudáfrica y en
la isla de la reunión que es un
departamento de ultramar francés que
está en el índico como ya lo decíamos en
américa esto este esta nueva variante
entró por canadá ya fueron detectados
hay algunos casos y brasil sería el
primer caso en américa latina
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
benjamín valiente él es médico experto
en medicina tropical y salud
internacional él está en la ciudad de
méxico también está con nosotros y la
nhtsa pero él es médico especializado en
salud pública y doctor del centro méxico
bienestar y salud nos atiende desde la
ciudad de los ángeles en california en
eeuu y en el estudio de france 24 nos
acompaña paola rojas estévez ella hace
parte del grupo genómica de
microorganismos emergentes del instituto
nacional de salud y también ella es
magíster en biología computacional
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales no
se encuentran como facebook en instagram
y en twitter como france24 bajo ese
arroba sant y luego es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y preguntas que quieran
hacer sobre este tema que nos concierne
a todos pues comienzo entonces con
benjamín en la ciudad de mexico
preguntándole sobre esta variante si era
algo previsto en el desarrollo no de una
pandemia de un virus como el sars co2 un
virus al que le venimos haciendo frente
ya casi dos años era previsible que
apareciera una variante del calibre de
omikron
y yo creo que sí así como han ido
apareciendo diferentes variantes en el
transcurso de toda esta pandemia que
apareciera una con tantas mutaciones era
algo esperado finalmente tenemos la
mayoría de la población mundial que no
está vacunada y tenemos un nicho
especial en los países que tienen baja
vacunación como lo es áfrica y
finalmente
alguna hipótesis bastante válida de esta
generación de nuevas variantes se
desarrollan que estas variantes pueden
surgir en entre más personas están
replicando el virus por supuesto pero
también entre estos pacientes que pueden
llegar a estar inmunodeprimidos o que
tengan defensas bajas por lo cual el
virus se puede replicar en su propio
cuerpo durante un mayor una mayor
cantidad de tiempo con casera con pues
eres normal es un doctor shapiro en la
ciudad de los ángeles su opinión nuestro
algo completamente previsible que nos
faltó de pronto para combatirlo
estamos simplemente un poco sobre
reaccionando ante la aparición de esta
variante y el mundo está tomándolo de
una manera un poco más alerta que en
casos anteriores
la realidad es que claramente y comparto
lo mismo que compañero en el momento que
nosotros dejamos abiertas las puertas y
dejamos gente porque nosotros como
humanos somos la mejor fábrica del cob y
19 el momento que nosotros no estamos
vacunados estamos ahora sí sintiéndonos
y bajamos la guardia y empezamos a no
usar cubrebocas no lavarnos las manos no
crear la unión todo esto hace que se
acerque el virus y tenga la posibilidad
al momento que entre nuestro cuerpo y
utilizan nuestras propias células
empieza a acumular muchos errores genes
y nosotros ya habíamos visto tres
opciones una de que realmente los
errores sean tantos que no se pueda
reproducir la segunda muy importante es
que tenga incremento de mortalidad y
gracias a dios no lo hemos visto y la
tercera opción como lo estamos viendo en
este momento con la de delta y también
económica que tenga tantas mutaciones
que realmente pueda evadir de alguna
manera sistema o pueda brincar entre
humano y humano mucho más frecuentemente
y esas son las cosas que tenemos que
tener mucho mucha precaución y aquí en
el estudio de france 24 le pregunto a
paola sus impresiones está el mundo
sobre reaccionando ante la aparición de
esta variante simplemente otra variante
más como las que ya hemos visto que
tiene sus características y está bajo
estudio pero tal vez estamos
sobredimensionando la situación tenemos
que alertar nos a que nos estamos
enfrentando bueno como lo mencionaba los
dos compañeros si hay que tener como
precaución en el seguimiento del virus
de sarco frost porque siempre nos
estamos enfrentando a este patrón de que
el virus siempre está cambiando siempre
está mutando y pues estas mutaciones
pueden ser buenas o malas para el darles
ciertas capacidades para poder
reproducirse a aumentar su infección y
demás
lo de sobreactuando creo que siempre
debemos estar pendientes llevar una
vigilancia genómica muy estricta para
poder detectar todos estos cambios
porque es algo que pues esperamos el
vídeo se está en constante y lo que hay
que hacer es no correr en círculos como
no entrar en pánico sino simplemente
llevar la vigilancia muy estricta y
poder hacer seguimiento de todos estos
cambios en las poblaciones ahora le
pregunto nos cuidamos lo suficiente o
estábamos bajando la guardia y por eso
es que llegamos a esta variante
estábamos avanzando en la vacunación en
algunos sectores del planeta no todas
las regiones están avanzando igual pero
como decían los médicos en algunas
regiones dejaron de usar los tapabocas
dejaron de pedir el distanciamiento
social el lavado de manos y todas estas
precauciones esto nos indica que tenemos
que seguir teniendo todas estas
precauciones porque pueden seguir
avanzando las variaciones del virus
claro nosotros estamos en una constante
pelea digamos los siguiente virus y
nuestro sistema inmune entonces al
momento que damos paso a que el virus
pueda hacer que el virus pueda como
contagiar a más personas este vídeo va a
mutar respecto a su huésped respecto a
cada persona entonces si disminuye la
vacunación se disminuye los cuidados de
cada una de las personas como en usar
tapabocas no vacunarse y demás está
dando paso a que estas personas puedan
infectarse y que el virus pueda a su vez
ir cambiando y ellos apareciendo este
tipo de mutaciones que le puede dar
ciertas propiedades y ventajas respecto
a nuestro sistema inmune o o la forma en
que nos defendemos claro le pregunto en
la ciudad de mexico al doctor valente a
que nos estamos enfrentando todavía o
micro en está bajo estudio para
determinar algunas cosas básicas que ya
vamos a analizar aquí a lo largo del
programa pero que se menciona en la
comunidad científica en la comunidad
médica de características que pueda
tener esta variante que no tenían las
variantes anteriores y que tenemos que
tener cuidado
mira yo creo que es una gran
interrogante también para nosotros en la
comunidad científica que nos estamos
enfrentando ahorita lo que sabemos es
que aparentemente y esto es muy
preliminar tiene una capacidad de
transmisión más eficaz pero tenemos
grandes interrogantes como qué tanto se
transmite que tanto las vacunas actuales
nos protegen que tanto el cambia la
presentación clínica de los pacientes es
más agresivo el virus y que tanto las
pruebas que todavía tenemos del
armamento diagnóstico en para
diagnosticar kobe 19 son útiles sirve la
prueba de antígeno que tanto sirven
centre entonces lo que tenemos en la
comunidad médica es interrogantes lo
mismo que tiene todo el mundo doctor
zafiro citó al profesor tulio de
oliveira que es el director del centro
de innovación y respuesta a epidemias en
sudáfrica el país que dio la alerta
mundial sobre la aparición de esta
variante él dice omicron posee una
constelación inusual de mutaciones y es
muy diferente a las otras variantes qué
significa
el virus o la variante más mutada hasta
la fecha qué quiere decir esto
poniéndole las palabras simples para los
televidentes claramente con muchísimo
gusto la mejor manera de explicar esto
es cuando nosotros tenemos un juguete
que lo podemos armar con diferentes
cubitos generalmente hacemos una casa y
podemos ver las ventanitas la puerta y
vemos el triangulito del techo al
momento que nosotros empezamos a ver que
el techo parte de un triangulito tiene
como dos chimeneas en lugar de tener dos
ventanas tienen una ventana por la
ventana es muy pequeña de repente la
puerta no está por la parte de la
entrada sino está por la parte de abajo
y está más que abrir la puerta todo esto
hace que no sea en la casa normal que
nosotros es justamente lo que los
científicos estamos viendo en este
momento el momento que está tan tan tan
diferente cuando nosotros lo presentamos
a nuestro cuerpo todas esas células
blancas que ya están listas y preparadas
por la vacunación para defenderse pues
no van a poder entender directamente si
es alguna casa o un platillo volador
entonces lo que le tenemos miedo en este
momento tantas mutaciones que nuestros
propios anticuerpos y ya entrenamos y
todas las células defensoras nos
ofrecían nuestros soldados prácticamente
no tengan las armas suficiente para
saber que eso es el hobby 19 porque se
está disfrazando porque porque los virus
intentan querer sobrevivir por llamarlo
de esa manera entonces de esa manera
está metiéndose por abajo posiblemente
en un sistema inmune todo lo que
nosotros estamos haciendo para entrenar
nuestro sistema inmune con las vacunas
tanto de diferentes tecnologías que
tenemos algunos tipos de cosas que
tenemos como los anticuerpos
monoclonales
podrían llegar a nuevo nada no
neutralizar al virus como nosotros
queremos y eso lo que estamos ahorita
viviendo
el doctor shapiro continuó con usted
para preguntarle usted menciona que los
virus intentan sobrevivir al cerco que
se les hace con las vacunas y con las
medidas que tomamos estamos ante un
virus que es muy inteligente y que logra
evolucionar muy rápido
o ante un virus que simplemente se
aprovecha de la situación que vivimos de
una leve mejora por el avance de la
vacunación y rápidamente se modificó
para hacerle frente precisamente a las
vacunas que están ahora en el mercado
disponibles
es una muy buena pregunta el contraste
completo es el siguiente hoy en día le
sigue la variante de alta siendo la
dominante que tenemos es ácido y por eso
mucha gente han preguntado todo eso pero
bueno ya ya salió a esto pues ya para
que me vacuno la realidad es que nuestro
problema el día de hoy que nos puede
afectar mucho más es la variante delta 2
de todos modos las vacunas que tenemos
hoy en día están funcionando y
protegernos dos por eso tenemos que
ponernos la serie completa o también la
refuerzo si es necesario por otro lado
los virus están diseñados de esa manera
para que puedan realmente moverse rápido
sobrevivir rápido y contagiar a más
personas porque de esa manera siguen
sobreviviendo el virus entonces entre
nosotros le dejamos la puerta abierta a
cualquier humano más variantes vamos a
tener y más problemas podemos tener a
largo plazo por eso es muy importante
tomar en cuenta que si estamos cansados
definitivamente estamos tristes que esto
empezó otra vez y pero se acerca ahorita
en la parte del año clave realmente para
que nos juntemos con otros humanos tanto
la navidad y el año nuevo se festejan en
muchas partes del año y del mundo más
que nada entonces esto puede amplificar
ahora si el riegue la sopa y por eso
tengo que poner atención el día de hoy
para protegerlos paola quien el estudio
en france 24 ya lo vemos los virus
tratan de sobrevivir a estos cercos que
les hacemos es
parte de su mecanismo de subsistencia
tratar de volverse una variante
dominante por encima de las otras es
decir omicron podría ser una variante
que trate de perpetuarse un poco más que
las otras variantes o relegar a delta
alfa gamma lambda que ya las hemos visto
en otras regiones del planeta aunque es
adif a todas no lo sabemos con certeza
lo que sabemos es que respecto a las
demás variantes que conocemos presentó
un alto número de mutaciones no no
quiere decir que porque tienen más
mutaciones es más poderosa o tiene más
ventajas pero toca ver o sea hay que ver
cada una de estas mutaciones y ver qué
implicaciones pues éstas pueden tener
puede llegar a ser puede llegar a tener
como más efectos o menos efectos que las
demás y es una de las razones que
ahorita nos mantiene como pendiente a
esta porque si comparamos el número de
mutaciones de alta actualmente se
registra 9 en mutaciones en esta zona
spike y con icon omicron vemos que hay
32 entonces uno se logra en presionar un
poco al ver ese gran número de
mutaciones y comparten mutaciones de
interés que tienen otras otras variantes
entonces la hace como nadia na
importante como lo mismo tener
seguimiento para ver si es casi como un
cóctel que reúne varias en las
mutaciones componentes de las otras
variantes en una sola exacta básicamente
sería así eso es lo que la hace especial
respecto a las demás y lo que llamó
tanto la atención doctor valente en la
ciudad de mexico le preguntó en ese caso
cuál podría ser entonces el mejor
escenario que podríamos tener le
pregunto porque sé que está en avance
toda esta investigación para determinar
los efectos que pueda tener si es más o
menos contagiosa si es más o menos
peligrosa todo esto en desarrollo pero
en ese caso para la supervivencia del
virus y para nuestra supervivencia cuál
podría ser el escenario más positivo de
resultado de estas investigaciones
en el escenario más positivo sin duda es
que
sea menos virulenta quiere decir tenga
una menor tasa de letalidad y de
severidad en las manifestaciones
clínicas de los pacientes que tienen
esta nueva variante entonces eso es el
mejor escenario ahora sabemos que se
transmiten más aparentemente estás un
dato preliminar pero sabemos que se
transmite más fácilmente entonces si
transmites más fácilmente una infección
alrededor del mundo va porque igual va a
ser la variedad la variante dominante
alrededor del mundo así como tomó ese
papel delta pues y si es menos virulenta
eso va a traer consigo una gran ventaja
al mundo pero ese es el escenario
positivo ese es el escenario positivo
que se pueden presentar es una gran
incógnita todavía ha llegado el caso en
que sea menos virulenta como usted lo
dice eso podría ser un inicio del fin de
la pandemia estaríamos de pronto viendo
que el virus está perdiendo fuerza como
como lo ve usted
por lo menos el
inicio del fin yo creo que sí o sea
sería un regalo de la naturaleza
que sea menos virulenta pero yo creo que
este virus desde mi punto personal de
vista llegó para quedarse va a quedar
como un corona mismas estacional
eventualmente en algunos años sí y tal
parece que se va a volver habitual entre
nosotros y ahí pasó a preguntarle al
doctor shapiro sobre las vacunas también
están investigación en desarrollo en
diferentes laboratorios si este virus es
mucho más agresivo y las vacunas no
pueden combatirlo de la misma manera si
definitivamente le pueden hacer
contrarrestar efectivamente para lo que
fueron diseñadas estas vacunas que se
sabe hasta el momento de las vacunas que
tenemos incluso las farmacéuticas ya han
dicho nosotros podemos modificar las
vacunas para combatir a omicron pero
cuanto toma eso
es una gran gran pregunta lo primero que
van a ver es buscar si las vacunas que
tenemos ahorita y eso hay que recordar
que hay más de 210 vacunas en todo el
mundo entonces hay que siempre poner en
este momento que digan que vacuna está
realmente diciendo bueno yo si puedo
defender muy bien no me puedo defender
contra estas nuevas variantes que
siempre hay que ponerle el nombre y
apellido a estas lo primero que vamos a
escuchar es que si neutralizan y generan
anticuerpos neutralizantes contra esta
variante y muchas veces ya de ahí como
muestras y prácticamente hacen en el
laboratorio experimentos donde pueden
ver que está funcionando en laboratorio
cuidado si está funcionando entonces
esto generalmente nos da mucha
tranquilidad entonces es lo que vamos a
estar esperando en las siguientes
semanas donde tanto fisher modernas y
johnson johnson y manejo de estas tres
vacunas porque son las que más datos han
abierto públicamente y después de esos
estas técnicas de miami no los hay que
tenga un poquito de paciencia y con esto
ya nos gustaría entender nuestro regalo
de navidad y que ya nos dijeran que ya
estamos bien y que las vacunas tenemos
porque tengo un poquito de paciencia
porque esto
acaba de empezar prácticamente unas
semanas atrás
y el movimiento para crear estas muchas
tomas
paola aquí en el estudio france24 le
preguntó sobre los virus en general no
solamente el sars coptos sino en los
virus en general pueden comportarse de
manera distinta dependiendo de el grupo
étnico que estén atacando digamos así es
distinto a un virus que ataca a los
afrodescendientes o personas que están
en el continente africano de raza negra
o personas blancas o de otro tipo de
razas esto varía dependiendo le pregunto
porque como surgió fue descubierta en
áfrica y los síntomas que se reportan
son distintos en europa que los que
están registrando en áfrica en algunos
casos del viene me pregunta
los videos se comportan y se van a
replicar diferentes respecto a sus peros
o sea respecto a la persona como tal
sin importar que sea blanco o negro pues
la parte técnica y esto hace que o sea
no podemos decir que entonces como fue
detectado en primera instancia por
sudáfrica entonces sea un virus que va a
actuar de esta manera y la
sintomatología va a variar también
respecto a la persona a su sistema
inmune y al estilo de vida de la persona
le cuidado ante la enfermedad entonces
incluso pues en sar que es lo que más se
conoce en general pues en la población
se ve que hay personas que sus síntomas
son más fuertes o sus síntomas son más
leves o incluso hay personas
asintomáticas que no presentan como
algún síntoma como tal y esto ha dado a
pues al sistema sus defensas y ya su
estilo de vida si le pregunto al doctor
valente y también al doctor shapiro los
dos pueden complementar esta pregunta y
es tal vez una de las inquietudes que
tienen
las personas del común la vimos esta
pregunta a través de las redes sociales
y es si las personas que están vacunadas
pueden volverse a contagiar de kobe 19
por esta variante no se sabe todavía si
de pronto o micro puede re infectar otra
vez a las personas que ya están
vacunadas o que ya padecieron kobe 19
que saben ustedes le pregunta el doctor
valente de primero
sabemos que si la realidad es que si lo
que no sabemos es en qué porcentaje la
vacuna deja de ser protectora y cuál es
la diferencia entre un esquema completo
o incluso un esquema de dos o tres dosis
no sé ya que tenga un refuerzo el
esquema de vacunación pero sabemos que
sí porque en el caso o en el caso índice
de esta variante un micrón de este
viajero que regresó a hong kong y que le
toman la muestra el 13 de noviembre un
viajero que está completamente vacunado
con país ser me parece entonces sabemos
que si lo que no sabemos es en qué
porcentaje doctor shapiro complementa
esta respuesta
la realidad es que muchas personas
estaban pensando que de hecho si les
tocaba a ellos mismos el 19 que iban no
están muy protegidos y ya sabemos de esa
parte que no una persona que ya tuvo el
19 es si crea anticuerpos que no son
suficientes para neutralizar el virus y
por otro lado tenemos una capa más
sabemos que el momento que tenemos la
vacuna mínimo sabemos qué cantidad y
protección estamos teniendo a tal grado
que vimos ahorita en verano en muchos
países donde la mayoría de las personas
que están siendo hospitalizada serán
personas no vacunadas entonces ni sentir
en este momento es que de todos modos no
hay ninguna vacuna al 100% tenemos
muchas vacunas y oportunidades que nos
protegen y es la idea tener un cinturón
de seguridad por si tenemos un accidente
poder sobrevivir y poder estar mucho
mejor que las personas que no lo tienen
por eso es sumamente importante ahorita
esperanza un poquito más y ver realmente
dónde estamos con esta información el
doctor zafiro en este momento muchos
países están estudiando la posibilidad
de inocular a sus ciudadanos con la
tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo otros
países ya han avanzado y un alto
porcentaje de la población ya la tiene y
esto surgió a raíz de la variante delta
ahora económica entonces nos enfrentamos
a una cuarta dosis eso quiere decir que
entonces la dosis completa de una vacuna
cuantas dosis puede tener cuanto puede
ser
el completo de inoculación para poder
quedar inmunes ante ante el coronavirus
en la respuesta hace un año eran dos en
este momento cuando estamos aprendiendo
y tenemos que recordar que tenemos
muchas vacunas por ejemplo la de polio y
otras más donde se utilizan varias
vacunas hasta que realmente nuestro
cuerpo entiende cómo protegernos de una
mejor manera entonces ahorita mientras
te puedo decir exactamente lo que vamos
estar viendo para ver si vamos a
necesitar o no más vacunas de refuerzo
también como secuela el esquema completo
de la vacuna la primera parte va a ser
ver las variantes son cubiertas por la
vacuna que tenemos si nosotros tenemos
nuevas variantes y el agua con la que
tenemos nosotros no está funcionando va
a ser importante volver a crear un
refuerzo y vamos por otra parte que
nuestro cuerpo empieza a bajar la
cantidad de anticuerpos que está
produciendo neutralizantes contra el
kobe 19 también sería un factor de
preocupación
aunado definitivamente porque tenemos
que ver también qué está pasando en los
hospitales con la mortalidad y también
con las complicaciones a cualquier edad
ya cualquier humano y estos cuatro
factores son las cosas que tenemos que
estar midiendo para ver si vamos a
necesitar esa cuarta dosis para hacer
eso por lo pronto en la oportunidad
pónganse la tercera dosis de las vacunas
que ya están aprobadas porque de esa
manera le están dando un recordatorio a
su cuerpo como usar definidos y sobre
todo ahora estamos subiendo los casos
está subiendo y están muy semejantes la
subida que el año pasado el 2020 es muy
importante estar próximos es decir que
sí le pregunto cuántos refuerzos de
vacunas va a ser posible es imposible
saber cuántos refuerzos entonces
me sacó hasta una sonrisa en este
momento en este momento sería la
respuesta más correcta entiendo doctor
en pavón aquí en el estudio de france 24
él le pregunto y también pregunta del
común de la gente inquietudes del
ciudadano cuánto puede resistir un
cuerpo teniendo vacunaciones periódicas
seis meses esto no afecta para nada los
organismos estamos expuestos a tener
cada seis meses que vacunarnos sentir
los efectos de la vacuna que es uno o
dos días de malestar en algunos casos
fiebre en algunos en algunos casos
también esto no no no viene mal para el
organismo o simplemente el cuerpo lo
acepta
no pues simplemente el cuerpo el cuerpo
lo afecta igual
estas vacunas las vacunas los tipo de
vacunas y el tiempo de vacunación que se
estipula ahorita seis meses ha sido
estudiado respecto a la respuesta del
sistema inmune y ha sido estudiado
respecto a la cantidad de anticuerpos de
hecho para complementar un poco la
pregunta anterior
nosotros hemos hecho bueno y se ha hecho
monitoreo como de la cantidad
anticuerpos que se generan durante las
dosis de las vacunas y acá en este
momento estamos
dando estamos invitando a ser la tercera
vacunación la tercera dosis porque hemos
visto que en la primera dosis nuestros
anticuerpos el que el que nos defiende
con el virus
aumentan pero a medida que va pasando el
tiempo estos anticuerpos se van
regulando y van disminuyendo entonces es
ahí cuando va bajando la curva que
necesitamos otro refuerzo entonces no
hay por qué pensar que nos va a hacer
daño si hay algunos síntomas pues
respecto a las vacunas como tú les
mencionaban mencionadas pero síntomas
que dan con cualquier otro tipo de
vacunas pues es importante
y recordar este mensaje a la ciudadanía
porque hay muchas personas que todavía
tienen dudas en torno a la tercera dosis
pero entonces paola así el escenario el
escenario maravilloso sería que la
tercera dosis sirviera también para
combatir esta nueva variante omicron que
eso podría llegar a suceder está en
estudio puede pasar no se puede pasar
pues aumentan nuestras defensas digamos
como que vamos a tener un ejército más
armado respecto al virus que viene si le
pregunto al doctor valiente por el tema
de las vacunas esto claramente nos
evidencia que sigue siendo completamente
desbalanceada la distribución de vacunas
a nivel mundial vemos que áfrica sigue
hemos relegado a américa latina hay va
lento pero seguro y europa sigue
acaparando las vacunas junto con eeuu
sus opiniones sobre este desbalance en
la entrega de vacunas a nivel
internacional doctor
bueno creo que la equidad
en salud es algo que nos falta mucho
trabajar con un mundo como humanidad y
tenemos que enfocarnos a que el
coronavirus es un enemigo común es un
enemigo que no tiene fronteras que no
distingue razas ni religiones entonces a
medida que trabajemos
en distribuir vacunas en todo el mundo
en que quizás se liberen las patentes o
sean un poco más laxas se produzcan más
vacunas se compartan más vacunas con el
tercer mundo y con los países en vías de
desarrollo será mejor para todos y esto
va también en relación con el acuerdo
reciente del g7 en el que se comprometen
estas naciones más desarrolladas en
compartir vacunas con el mundo
subdesarrollado
doctor valentín como esto estando en
estudio está en desarrollo están
investigando todos los efectos que pueda
tener esta variante algunos países han
tomado unas medidas radicales han sido
criticados en la comunidad internacional
por ejemplo israel cerró sus fronteras
no entran ciudadanos extranjeros
solamente israelíes que estaban por
fuera en lo mismo están haciendo algunos
países europeos frente a paz
o viajeros que llegan de áfrica
japón también cerró sus fronteras esta
medida puede ser exitosa mientras avanza
la investigación
blindar otra vez los países o de todas
maneras el virus va a llegar tarde que
temprano en esta variante en esta nueva
modalidad de variante del virus va a
llegar tarde que temprano sea esta
medida lo único que compra es tiempo es
esto de cerrar fronteras son medidas de
mitigación epidemiológica que tienen un
costo humano costo bastante alto un
costo incluso monetario también bastante
alto y que en algunos países es
completamente inviable yo creo que nos
tenemos que dirigir e ir en
tomar acciones
como lo dictan la organización mundial
de la salud incrementar la vigilancia
epidemiológica de las variables acelerar
la vacunación uso de cubrebocas
distanciamiento social estar en lugares
ventilados y por supuesto evitar eventos
masivos y
preparar nuestros sistemas sanitarios
para lo que puede venir eso es lo más
importante el estar preparado es lo más
importante ante una pandemia en la cual
no sabemos qué rumbo va a tomar esa es
la realidad no sabemos el rumbo y
mientras tanto pues podemos seguir con
las medidas básicas que hemos venido
implementando a lo largo de estos meses
me quedan ya pocos minutos para terminar
el programa esto se fue muy rápido en la
conclusión creo que lo más certero aquí
será preguntarles a ustedes que va a
seguir que viene aquí en adelante para
esta pandemia estamos ante muchas
variantes que van a venir en el futuro
este virus comenzará a decaer un poco y
nos dará un respiro comienzo con paola
aquí en el estudio de france 24 que
sigue no hay bola de cristal no sabemos
el futuro pero como de usted el panorama
que siguen cuidados constantes no
descuidarnos tapabocas vacunas no tener
miedo a digamos las consecuencias de
vacunarse como fiebre dolor de cabeza de
seguro va a ser mucho peor tener los
síntomas que da el cobat y más si no
tienes ni siquiera una vacuna el virus
puede actuar más fuerte
y respecto al virus pues no sabemos
vigilarlo hacer el seguimiento seguir
hace una vigilancia genómica muy
estricta en todos los países y para
poder pues estar preparados algo que
viene porque como tal de cómo se ha
comportado que va a ser el virus en el
mundo es muy complicado saberlo con
certeza pero entonces vendrán más
variantes eso sí puede llegar a pasar
pues el vídeo se está cambiando
constantemente puede pasar que se hagan
más variantes doctor valente sus
impresiones que puede venir para la
humanidad frente a esta pandemia
yo creo que hay dos posibles principales
la primera es que se extinga por
completo porque el número de contagiados
alcanza cierto no a cierto porcentaje y
a la vez hay cierto porcentaje de
inmunidad de rebaño con las vacunas y le
ganamos la carrera al virus y continúan
surgiendo mutaciones y
necesitamos de nuevas vacunas esas son
las dos posibles que yo veo a mediano
plazo el doctor zafiro lo dejo para el
cierre del programa su conclusión y su
perspectiva de lo que puede venir para
esta pandemia para esta nueva variante y
para el futuro de las vacunas de una vez
aprovechó y le pregunto
dos situaciones reales la primera nos
ponemos las pilas y le creamos muchas
barreras nos vacunamos hacemos un
milagro mundial y pasamos una navidad de
un año nuevo en barrera de esa manera
pues va a ser mucho mejor que el año
pasado pero de todos modos con
precauciones para la pandemia esta sería
la primera parte la segunda es que si no
llegamos una vacunación importante y
aparte no nos estamos cuidando y estamos
siendo más situaciones donde estamos
contagiando a los más más variantes más
problemas y más dolores de cabeza
la vacuna sigue siendo la arma más
efectiva que nosotros tenemos hay que
recordar que son más de 210 en el mundo
que se están creando entonces hay que
tener paciencia con eso hablar siempre
del nombre y apellido de las vacunas y
muy importantes luchan contra la
desinformación en este momento es la
otra ola de problemas que estamos
teniendo es cuando las personas no se
controlan y están poniendo retweet y
mandando cosas que no son ciertas o
simplemente por miedo no pregunta
entonces es el momento para crear
conversaciones crean realidad y muy
importante hay que vacunarnos contra el
miedo con una dosis de verdad
importante es el mensaje doctor shapiro
pues a los tres invitados les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros aquí a
paola en el estudio de france 24 al
doctor shapiro en la ciudad de los
ángeles y al doctor valente en la ciudad
de mexico gracias por habernos explicado
este tema que está en este momento en la
lupa de la comunidad internacional y
pues muy atentos a los desarrollos que
pueda tener la comunidad científica en
torno a la información sobre la variante
o micro en mientras tanto a seguir
cuidando nos a vacunarnos la tercera
dosis para quienes todavía les hace
falta y a seguir cuidando nos con el
tapabocas y el lavado de manos y el
distanciamiento social ustedes pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios y las
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
de france 24 sigan con nosotros buenas
noches